[Musique]
qu'est ce que le cosplay une pratique où
l'on doit faire qu'un avec notre
personnage favori être reconnaissable en
un coup d'oeil
anicet afida turner règles et c3po
aurélien est doué
se rend-il à la hauteur excuse moi
d'après toi c'est qui je sais pas à
votre avis je suis en quel personnage je
sais pas j'ai un peu du mal je reconnais
pas du tout un mec qui dort avec un
pyjama t sur lattes est sur la bonne
voie on peintre non c'est un marsupilami
nombreux quines pad n'ont pas d'honneur
presque plus cultes encore en oeuf sur
le plat et donner un indice indice c'est
facile de quel monde est à peu près
c'est plus une série et c'est plus la
saison 2 loft story
ça ne me dit rien du tout je suis
vraiment désolé
je suis mignon a pas moi le personnage
michael jackson
je suis un enfant je les aurai décoller
chu mignon dans un film w9 en plusieurs
épisodes schneck propos du tout cesnek
woman c'est un peu chez nec ou one de
tennis en fête a vu une balle de tennis
va fut l'américain qui fait ça je te
fais une petite anse pour pipeau pipeau
tweed ouïe ouïe
[__] non vraiment pas merci quand même
chez afida turner [__] ça se voit y'a
pas que san goku 1 c'était c3po dans
star wars
afida turner mec je me regardais énervé
tu me regardes gentiment blasé on va
dire cool tralala les [__] les proies
les gens ne reconnaissent pas c'est
incroyable ça c'est pas le mur c3po que
tu as vu tous les temps on dirait qu'on
dirait tellement c3po je suis comprend
pas et on dirait pas la fille de la
tournure si on dirait vachement afida
turner mais juste le petit hic c'est
qu'à fait la dernière c'est pas hyper
univers geek et où tu veux je me disais
on se mettait en personnage de manga
les gens ils reconnaîtraient plus
peut-être est d'accord mais on fait quel
manga
on n'a qu'à faire le meilleur manga de
tous les temps
est-ce que vous avez le meilleur manga
de tous les temps mais bien sûr totally
spies
on est qui yes totally spies
yes on est les totally spies totally
totally total incroyable tout le monde
le reconnaît
ils l'ont fait à force d'abnégation ils
ne font plus qu'un avec les totally
spies
en fait on cherche une idée de cosplay
pour l'année prochaine donc n'hésitez
pas à nous dire quel est le meilleur
manga pour vous dans les commentaires
après totally spies of course